[Music]
okay so i have
i'll do it okay
i have
jesse ventura
being interviewed by andrew yang
hey guys it's the collaboration nobody
wanted nobody asked for it for getting
it guess what i was about to say why oh
well
i don't know if you know this but andrew
yang has a podcast called
forward
so how did you come to this conclusion
that these two parties are not actually
trying to work in the people's interest
when did that click for you
well when i said the vaccine was amazing
lying here in my bed right taking the
vaccine dude he's starting to look like
him yeah he's trying to look like steve
winklebomb
he looks
rough
i am a mutant now
looks like he's about to make a pun
about a werewolf and introduce a [ __ ]
kitschy horror film i was gonna say
tails from the crib virginia i swear to
god
[Music]
this next one will take your breath away
[Laughter]
for me over something very simplistic
andrew
i love the vaccine now
the fact
all the shaking stopped
entire political system
based upon the concept of bribery the
only way you're going to get an audience
is by becoming a fake governor and then
getting a discovery channel tv show
where you're exposed conspiracy theorist
one of them being you are you've been a
rampant anti-vaxxer and then saying that
you took it because you had to
show this show where it's clear alex
jones pretty much did all of the
homework
the official
of a democrat or republican persuasion
is bring a check how about this
yang ventura
2024 no thanks okay
you know don't bring your problem bring
a check dude i'm really glad that he
wore his best uh his best tank top for
the interview
seriously like no
look man we don't dress up but at least
we have sleeves on
okay
with your problem
and then you'll at least get your
audience see they've turned our system
into a complete system of bribery and
what's weird about that is that if you
do that in the private although pfizer
doesn't bribe anybody
they're completely on the level
everyone else is bribing people
right
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you go to where's your feather boa
oh god this is the intro to his stupid
podcast
music i know he's playing ching chong
music why don't you just call it free
money with [ __ ] with andrew yang
it's ching chong i feel like i'm in the
japan pavilion in epcot right
[Music]
all right
this is true this intro is too long
right yeah i know we have a long intro
but at least ours says words
it is my pleasure i'm going to say honor
my honor and privilege to welcome this
guy thought he was going to be president
yeah and then he thought he was going to
be mayor of new york they'll punch him
in new york he can't be mayor there
word perhaps
the greatest independent politician
about it though to be the only mayor in
history that could actually like grab an
uber eats bicycle yeah it's a good place
to just ride around and blend in with
the [ __ ] citizens
though he calls himself a statesman i
think that's accurate so the
independent statesman of our time
honestly this guy brought you food would
you even notice no i really wouldn't
know his angel right i swear to god i'm
not even trying to be right
i'm not even saying it as a joke i'd be
like even with that hat on he looks even
the hat of a new of a of a chinese food
delivery guy just what he looks like
just yeah i wouldn't there'd be no oh my
god are you andrew yang yeah just oh
thank you you go keep the change
that in a big way
personal note you just got a new car is
that right
what yeah i i'm in a great mood i uh i
got a my new car was just delivered to
me on fridays
[Laughter]
uh it's a brand new tesla i knew that
was coming
of course it's gonna be a tesla he loves
tesla i thought you live in like the
mexican desert where you're gonna get a
tesla charging station he plugs it into
the little to the little shack next to
his house run off a diesel fuel that he
has to get brought in every day are you
going to stop at the sinaloa wawa
is there charging their tesla charging
stations
and uh i'm 70 years old now and i can
proudly look way older yeah i mean wow
you age very poorly say i own the
fastest car currently on the planet
i'll tell you why i i drive i don't
drive really you own a ferrari
no the tesla's the fastest car now
60 yeah because there's no engine it's
immediate acceleration
things here to 60 and 2.1 or something
yeah but they suck i'm not saying they
still in sucker suck i'm sorry i guess
i'm just doing old jeremy clarkson yeah
i agree i want to hear the car anymore
and i'm probably i won't even probably
break the speed limit that much with
this car
but i will admit to one thing
i'm a person who occasionally needs an
adrenaline
that's why he took the vaccine
i mean we all know that feeling that you
occasionally i gotta have that you know
i had 34 parachute jumps
oh royce i know he was i don't know if
you know this
i know
i know okay
i've done a lot of things in my life
that give me that type of adrenaline
rush and
the tesla can do that and i is this i'm
sorry i have a question
is this sponsored by tesla i'm trying to
understand brought to you by tesla i'm
skipping ahead a little bit
to join the screen actors deal
i now had a union
so when i then came back to vince i said
to him during the negotiations i said
well vince i said you don't have to
worry about me yelling about the union
no more he said oh really why not i said
i got mine i said if the rest of these
guys are too chicken [ __ ] or don't want
to put it up to stand up for it i'm not
going to get my head cut off no more i
got my union i'm a member of the screen
actors guild and will be till i retire
and i get health benefits from them
everything
wow unions are so good
brought to you by tesla
where we don't want to have a union
[Music]
thank you that is one hundred percent
true
holy [ __ ] i didn't even think about it
brought to you by tesla where eli won't
even let you say the word union
everything that you won't provide we
won't even let you watch old wwe uh
attitude era segments that had the union
in it he doesn't even let you read about
the civil war no
so you don't have to worry i'm not gonna
do that well
later on when i sued vince for royalties
and beat him during the depositions i
told my attorneys
because you can ask about anything in a
deposition i said i told them the whole
story and i had great attorneys i said
if you can find out
please find out who ratted me
who was the guy who of the wrestlers
ratted me out that day that i stood up
and tried to unionize or offered them
the ability to balls it out and see if
we could do it yeah so during the
deposition my attorney goes well mr
mcmahon he goes uh
other sports have unions he goes is
there is there a union in wrestling and
vince of course answers no under oath uh
my attorney goes well has anyone ever
tried to form a union in wrestling
and vince had a moment and paused and he
goes well yeah he said i think and he
pointed to me across the table i think
uh yeah i think jesse ventura spouted
his mouth off about it once or whatever
i remember seemed to remember that
and my attorney said well when did you
hear me we know it's all hogan
we know oh my god
sixth largest city
sixth largest city and then you run for
governor and win against
guns
chuck norris gun club i have no idea if
this is true but it's still funny to
hear about brandy macho man savage
smacked him in the mouth called him a
commie [ __ ]
god i hope that's true i doubt it but
god damn it
for that to be true
we can party and the vast majority of
democrats are just painting all
republicans with a certain brush um
maybe they're they're saying like hey
um you know yeah good for them but no
one's really doing anything to try jesse
has the white stuff in the corner of his
mouth yeah he's a mess jesse you used to
think the jews controlled the weather
with heart machines can you [ __ ] stop
being mr union tesla guy now
shut the [ __ ] up ryan preserve let's say
i didn't say he was wrong i just said
that's what he believed i'd like to know
if pfizer has as a union
brought to you by pfizer
yeah
i would really love to know
if pfizer gave him money or rt money or
something
because the the 180 on that was was
shocking shot because he was really he
used to get so much [ __ ] for his
anti-vac stuff he's seen the rest of it
um so the republican party is getting
overrun in the very few figures another
guy who stood up and and voted to
impeach trump who's also up for
re-election who has better chances uh
peter meyer uh in in michigan
so this is just we it's
you you want neocons everybody that was
like yang is actually reasonable yang is
yang is a [ __ ] communist i don't mind
republicans as long as they vote like
democrats as long as they're you know as
long as they voted to impeach trump i'm
listening
is a great republican who could win
[ __ ] look at him he looks like he's
in the sand lot he looks like a
diverse remake of the sandlot he'd be
ching chong charlie or some [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] whatever kids would
call him you know
and you know like they're they're
demonstrating courage on a level that i
don't think most people appreciate um
and yeah it's really courageous to side
with the party that [ __ ] wins all the
time and then has people arrested oh
they're so courageous to have a [ __ ]
uh a golden parachute to work at cnn or
msnbc oh the courage it takes to stand
up to trump somebody that was
universally loved apparently in their
heads
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] suck
democrats are not helping them because
of just this bizarre polarization in the
system where they look at it and be like
so bizarre where did it come from nobody
knows no nobody knows that's the scary
part is that it could be any one of us
somebody put him in the hot dog and say
i want him in the hot dog we're all
trying to figure out the guy who did
this
who could it be now
but it's like
you do you create the problem and then
you're like man this is a problem
somebody said that andrew yang was
awesome in the goonies
he's data
mr jones
that kid had a good little run yeah he
actually just after years he just did a
couple moves with the kid he came back
and was in that new movie everything
everywhere all the time and it's funny
because he's an adult man but he still
talks the same way and it was freaking
me out
you know like all republicans are bad
even the ones that in this case are
trying to fight to preserve
uh democracy in the face of trump
like dan crenshaw and lindsey graham
heroes
heroes
if it was up to yang he give universal
basic influence to ukraine too from our
[ __ ] money well he's at it the most
dangerous thing we have right now andrew
the vaccine
is not the is not the republicans in
congress
i believe right now the most dangerous
thing we have
is that for sure
we have two dishonorable liars on the
supreme court
that that i mean that the entire country
has been uh very very inflamed over the
recent decision which i disagree with no
the liars not even there
and the fact that they they lied about
they lied to you on their way in andrew
let me put it to you this way you're a
private sector guy you have been pretty
much your whole life
if you go in with a job application
and on that job application most of them
asked he didn't lie you old [ __ ]
tales of the [ __ ] [ __ ]
what they said what they always say they
they never either side left or right
when they ever they ask him about a
certain decision whether it be guns or
whether it be [ __ ] or whether it be
[ __ ] abortion roe v wade they always
go i'm not going to talk about something
a case that's already been settled that
does not mean if a new thing comes up or
forget a new thing or if they re-examine
an old one they're allowed to do that
you go [ __ ] yourself because though they
changed precedence so you know what
that's separate but equal was the
supreme court decision that was fine and
then brown versus the board of education
[ __ ] changed that and they changed it
because [ __ ] these people god damn it
yeah isn't that why you always talk
about our gun rights and say hey they're
amendments they're meant to be amended
[ __ ] sometimes you got to go back in and
amend stuff women could vote now
unfortunately
yeah
does he ever address the [ __ ] vex
probably not i'm hold on
how to build the third party
system of bribery winning as an
independent
chaney's showed a lot of uh courage and
people and she may lose
and right now she's uh no liz cheney's
not gonna may lose this cheney is losing
there's no way
there's no way liz cheney's [ __ ]
winning stop [ __ ] stop pretty
significant underdog um in her
reelection campaign i've been tracking
the
trajectories of the republicans who
voted either to impeach trump or to
oppose in some way and what a weird
what a weird thing for this little
[ __ ] creepy dude to track right yeah
out of all the things i know i only want
the ones that want to do impeachment who
cares
it's really really dark man i know i
think there were 10 oh it's really dark
because all of them devoted to impeach
trump are going to lose because
everybody knows it's a [ __ ] ruse by
the way we're not even defending we get
[ __ ] now for [ __ ] on trump but [ __ ]
you that is [ __ ]